[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW PHILIPS: Hi, everyone.
Thank you very much for coming.
I know we still have a
bunch of people coming in.
We've got so much
material to cover,
I really want to make sure
we get started on time.
Thanks also to everyone
joining on the livestream.
We're going to talk about
canary deployments using
Istio and Kubernetes with
Spinnaker or other tools.
My name is Andrew Philips.
I'm a product manager in GCP,
working on continuous delivery.
NORA LUTZ: And I'm Nora Lutz,
Site Reliability Engineer
at Descartes Labs, but
I like to say that I'm
a recovering systems admin.
I've been in this industry
for just under 10 years.
Got my start in high performance
computing and research
at Old Dominion University.
Around three years ago, I
moved into geospatial and earth
observation at NASA.
And it was around
that same time,
I started working within
the Kubernetes ecosystem.
So now I'm at Descartes Labs.
And I'm really excited
to share some of stuff
we'll be working on.
ANDREW PHILIPS: Thanks, Nora.
So let me briefly give a
quick overview of what we're
going to try and cover today.
I'm going to start with
a quick introduction
to what's the actual
challenge, what's
the problem we want to address.
I'm going to do a very quick
recap of what Kubernetes also
offers out of the box for
application roll-outs.
We're going to use
some of those options
to talk about the
pattern that you can use
to implement canary analysis.
We're going to
talk about what you
get if you add Istio into the
mix, some additional options.
And then we're going to stop
with the theory in my slides.
And Nora is going to talk
about what this actually
looks like in practice
at Descartes Labs.
Just a quick reminder,
if you have questions,
you can post them in the Dory
that has a link in your app
that you click.
And feel free to post them there
at any time during the session.
We've got a lot of material.
I hope we'll have time
to answer the questions.
You can also ask questions live.
I think there's a
couple of mics around.
We'll try and alternate.
We'll try and get to as
many of those as we can.
So let's start by
briefly talking
about what the actual challenges
that we want to solve here.
I think we kind of
all roughly know
deployment is all about
moving fast without breaking
too many things.
So we want to roll out new
versions of applications.
We want to do that safely.
Should be easy.
We don't want people to have to
follow a 12-step cube-ctl guide
or whatever.
It should be reliable.
Ideally, it works
well when you do it,
but also if something doesn't
quite work as expected,
you should have good
fallback options.
And then, of course
in an ideal world
we want it to be
aligned with whatever
is considered best practice.
And if we're talking a
Kubernetes environment,
a lot of that revolves
around how can we
do this in a declarative way,
where we focus on our intent
rather than exactly
the details of how
we're trying to roll that out.
So just high level,
what's the scenario
that we're talking about here?
Nothing too particularly fancy.
And in general, I
should say, the main aim
from my perspective, we're not
going to talk about magic here.
Most of you may
know all the things
that we're talking about here.
It's more about
representing a pattern
so that you can take
away with some guidance
and some confidence.
But the overall scenario
is the [INAUDIBLE] version
x of my application
is running somewhere.
We'll assume it's
serving web traffic.
Most of what we're
going to talk about
applies equally
well to applications
that do things like processing
messages off a cube.
But for the purpose
of the diagrams
and so on, we'll
assume that there's
a web serving application.
And then you've got a new
version, y, coming out of your
build process or
your CI process,
and you want to switch users
over to that application.
So at a high level, the
sort of simple diagram
is you've got a load
balancer of some sort,
you've got a running
version of your application,
v1 in this case, magic happens.
Everything is safe and
reliable and wonderful.
Tah-dah!
We finish with version 2
of my application running.
That's really, in
a nutshell, all
that we're going to
talk about, how to try
to make this work really well.
So a quick recap.
What does Kubernetes already
give you out of the box?
Most of you are
probably familiar
with the deployment
object, specifically,
if you look at
the rolling update
strategy of the
deployment object,
there's already a pretty good
option for out of the box
magic, if you like, as we
just saw in that slide.
And what you get with
a deployment object
is what we might call a
rolling blue green cutover.
Talk about that a
little bit in a second.
And there are also
some useful controls
that you have to handle
how much over-provisioning
of new resources you want,
and how quickly you want
the old resources to
die away, specifically,
there's two parameters, max
surge and max unavailable,
that you can use to tune this.
So there's already some
pretty nice options.
And what you get is a picture
that looks a bit like this.
You've got service.
You've got your
deployment object, which
is managing a replica set.
It starts out here.
You decide to switch to v2,
spins up any replica set,
adds new pods, more another
one, dot, dot, dot, finished.
Great.
So that's what you
can do out of the box.
And the parameters control
how many new ones you spin up,
how quickly the
old ones go away.
So what's good about this?
Well, I guess the best thing--
it works out of the box.
You can pretty much do this
without any real effort.
You have stable
naming, which is nice.
It means that the resource
name, if you like,
that your application
workload refers to,
is the same like even v1, v2.
If that's not part
of the name, you
can just pull in your workload.
And you don't need to
do anything low level
like managing labels.
It just works.
But there's also
some limitations
that come with this.
And when I say limitations,
I should be clear.
This can be perfectly fine
for 80%, 90%, maybe 100%
of your use cases.
So just because
there are some things
you can't do with a
deployment object,
absolutely doesn't mean that
it might not be good enough
for everything that you need.
But for example, one thing
that is not that easy to do
is when one of your
new versions comes up,
you can't really get in
there and manipulate it
very well before it
actually gets traffic.
You can play a bit
with the health check,
but it's not that
easy to control
that in a fine grained way.
The traffic cutover process--
it's kind of baked into what
the deployment object does.
Like, as the new pods become
healthy, they get traffic.
You don't have a lot of fine
grained control about that.
And also in terms
of fallback options,
like, once the
deployment has happened,
and if you don't like
the way v2 is behaving,
you kind of got to do
the process in reverse
to go back to v1.
You can get the old revision,
but for example, you
don't have a running
instance that you can quickly
switch traffic back to.
So if we need some
more flexibility here,
we can do some things that are
a little bit more fine grained
than what the deployment
object provides.
And so we're trading a little
bit more effort on our part
to actually make this work
with more flexibility and more
options that we have.
So as an example, we can do
a full blue green deployment.
I'll show a diagram
in a second, which
is not a rolling
blue green, where
we get the whole new
application running.
And then we can do
things with that
and then we can
switch traffic over.
For example, we can use that
as a pattern to carry out
more extensive validation
of the new workload
before we decide to
expose our users to it.
So a high level might
look something like this.
So you've got a load balancer.
You've got your current version
of your application running.
You spin up the new version.
So now you've got this
thing sitting there
in a sort of dark launch
pattern where it's not
getting any traffic yet, but the
app is running, it's warmed up,
you can run things against it.
You decide it's good to
switch your traffic over.
Now your users are
using the new version,
but you still have the
old version around,
which is useful.
Imagine your apps take
a while to boot up.
If there's a problem now, you
can easily switch traffic back
to the old version, and
those apps will serve traffic
straight away.
You wait and then you
can have this standing
around for a while.
And eventually, when you're
confident that the new version
really is good, then
of course, you probably
want to get rid of
the old resources
so that you don't have them
standing around forever.
I actually have some
wonderful slides-- well,
I think wonderful-- that talk
about how to do this in detail
with Kubernetes.
We don't have, I think, enough
time to cover them today.
If you're interested, please
come up and see me afterwards.
So that gives us one pattern.
But if we need even
more safety than this--
so there's a few things that
can go wrong with this pattern--
we can use that blue green
pattern that we talked about.
And instead of just
switching traffic
over when the new
app is running,
we can decide to
perform some more tests.
We can run a suite of
integration or performance
tests, or even allow a
set of limited users--
our internal friends
or maybe a set of ERP
customers to hit the
new version of the app.
We can do a sort of manual very,
or a very slow rolling update
if you like.
So if you go back
to the picture,
rather than bringing up
all the new instances,
we can bring up a few.
And then we can
switch traffic over.
And we can slowly,
slowly increase
the amount of instances
that serve traffic,
and slowly, slowly
decrease the old version.
It's basically what the
deployment object does,
but we can control the stages
in which that happens, or we
can do a canary roll up,
which is another pattern that
allows us to inject some more
safety into this process.
So I think most of you will
have heard of this term before.
I'll define it for the
purposes of this discussion.
What is a canary roll out?
Well, it's a way of evaluating
a candidate version, which
is the new version we want to
deploy, against the baseline,
which is related to the
currently running version most
of the time, to check
for unexpected deviations
of behavior.
So this is not about functional
testing or something like that.
This is not about checking
whether the new version does
what you want it to do.
You have a new feature, you want
to make sure the feature works.
No, it's about verifying
that the new version behaves
acceptably, whatever that means,
with respect to the existing
version.
So for example,
the CPU utilization
doesn't go through the roof
or something like that.
And this is useful if the
application's behavior
across the metrics
that you're measuring
is not expected to change a lot.
Of course, there are
types of changes.
Imagine you've added
the CPU fix where you're
expecting the
application's performance
to behave quite differently.
And so as part of your
analysis of your canary
to figure out whether you
should go ahead or not,
you need to be able
to take these kinds
of expected deviations
into account as well.
And Nora is going to talk
a little bit about some
of the things that you can
do in your canary analysis
to make this work.
So what's the schematic
for a canary rollout?
Well, you start with
a load balancer.
You've got your
current app running.
And then you move to
this intermediate state
in which you have your
current running app
and you have a baseline
and you have a candidate.
Why the baseline?
It's very common to see what
I might call simple canary
approaches where you just
compare the candidates
with the existing version.
That's OK, but it's really not
an apples to apples comparison.
To take a simple
example, the baseline
or the original version is
serving much more traffic
than the candidate.
So it might behave differently
just because of that.
It's also been
running for however
long it's been running,
whereas the candidate has just
booted up.
And so if you want a proper
side by side evaluation,
you should have a baseline
that matches the candidate
as closely as possible.
And that means it should serve
the same percentage of traffic,
and it should have been spun
up and configured in roughly
the same way as the candidate.
So you run this
for a while and you
decide if you want to go ahead.
Great, you can get rid of the
baseline in the old version
and just switch all the
traffic to your new version.
And I'm glossing over how that
evaluation process happens.
Nora is going to talk a lot
more about some tips and tricks
about how to get that right.
Or if it doesn't work
out, you decide OK,
that wasn't a good idea.
Goodbye baseline.
Goodbye candidate.
And then we're back to serving
traffic with the old version,
and we try again.
So how do we do this
with Kubernetes vanilla?
We can use label
selectors on the service.
And we can use appropriate
sizing of our baseline
in our candidate to
approximate the traffic
distribution that we want.
We could use replica
sets, for instance,
but we would recommend
using a deployment object
for the workload
just because that's
the thing Kubernetes uses
for these kind of workloads.
And for consistency, with
the way the common deployment
object works, we recommend that
if you do decide to go ahead,
instead of switching traffic
over to your candidate,
you actually just update
the existing deployment
object in place.
So that way it looks just
like a regular update if you
weren't using canary analysis.
So what's the schematic if we're
doing this with Kubernetes?
We have a service.
We have a deployment.
And we have some
labeled selectors
that are pointing at
the current workload.
I'm using the conventional ones.
They're useful.
You might want to use your own.
That's not a hard and
fast recommendation.
Notice that the label selector
here is quite specific.
And you'll see in
a second why it
has this component equal
server additional selector,
because as we move into
the intermediate stage,
where we have three
deployments all of a sudden,
we obviously have to loosen
the label selector so
that it hits all three.
Label selectors
on services don't
support the set-based selector.
So that's how we're
going to do this.
And now we have traffic roughly
distributed across the three
different deployments.
And so that's where
the sizing comes in.
We have six and one and one.
And that gives us roughly
this distribution.
I say roughly,
because that's really
heavily dependent on the
characteristics of your load
balancer of your service.
So don't assume just because
the math of the sizing
works out like this.
But that's what
you're going to get.
If you want to do vanilla
canary with Kubernetes,
we highly recommend that you run
some experiments to figure out
whether you're actually
getting this kind of traffic
distribution, because
load balances have
lots of intelligence built in
that might make this different.
I should say one quick thing.
One thing that you need in order
to spin up the baseline here,
you need access to the
deployment configuration
of your current app.
And so that means that
you have to get that
either from the runtime
or from a GitOps repo
or whatever you have.
It's not just the
new deployment object
that you need to speed this up.
All right.
Need to speed up here.
So we decide to go ahead, great.
We narrow down the
label selector again.
We update the new version.
It does its rollout, one,
two, three, wait, done.
Wonderful.
So now we have our canary
deployment finished.
So if we need more
sophistication, this works.
And you can do vanilla
canary with Kubernetes
in this pattern.
But if we need some
more sophistication,
we noticed there
were already some--
well, a little bit of--
so I wouldn't say friction,
but the sizing was already
a bit of a challenge, we can use
Istio to do more things here.
So here's a service mesh.
Heard a lot about it.
It has many more
features and many more
use cases than just
traffic distribution
in a canary rollout.
But it's a very
useful thing to use
if you're interested in doing a
more sophisticated canary too.
So there's two main
things that we're
going to talk about
today that are useful,
one is that it supports
fine grained traffic splits,
and the other, that you
can do content based
rooting in your canary as well.
I think that's a bit
of an advance topic.
It's not that everyone has to
go away and implement that,
but it's nice to know
that it's possible.
So there's two Istio
resources that we
need to know about if we're
going to use it like this.
There's the destination rule.
And this defines subset.
So that's resources to which
traffic should be sent.
And then there's
the virtual service,
which defines the
rooting, basically
match rules that say under
these particular conditions,
take the traffic and send
it over to these subsets
and send this much
of the traffic.
So in practice, a subset of
the yaml looks a bit like this.
Over on the
destination rule, you
have a subset called my app.
Same label selector we used.
And then over on the
virtual service side,
you have a route that says
take all the HTTP traffic
and send it over
to subset my app.
And so the picture looks
quite similar to what we
had just now with Kubernetes.
You've got your
destination rules up there.
You've got your virtual service.
It has a subset.
It's sending all the
traffic over here.
And now we add the
two new deployments.
That's outside of Istio.
That's just regular Kubernetes.
But now we add this yaml
to our Istio configuration.
We define two new subsets.
It's much more legible up there
than it is here, which is nice.
We define the candidate
in the baseline.
And we use label selectors to
point specifically at those.
And then we add a
weight distribution
over on the virtual
server side, which
says that we're going to
split the traffic 90-5-5,
in this case.
So we end up with a picture that
looks a little bit like this.
And notice that we can have
a traffic distribution here
that is different
from the sizing
of the individual replica
sets, which is really nice.
So one of the nice
things we can do,
if you only have 5% of
traffic on your canary
in your baseline, it
might take a while
to get enough data to make
a good canary decision.
You might not want
to wait that long.
So as you've gained a
little bit of confidence
that your canary
is doing well, you
might want to ramp
up the traffic.
And you can do
that really easily
with this kind of
configuration change in Istio.
And then again, without
changing the sizing,
you now have 80-10-10,
which is nice.
One important point
to bear in mind here.
As you decide to ramp up
more and more traffic,
you pretty much
want to make sure
that you have a horizontal port
auto scalar on those replica
sets, because you don't
want them to fall over
as you said and 50% of
traffic or 40% or whatever,
to your canary and your
baseline or your candidate
and your baseline.
So now if we decide
to go ahead, great.
We can get rid of the
subset definitions,
and we can change the
weight distribution back.
And we can update the
deployment object.
And then we make that change.
And as before, it goes through
its regular deployment pattern,
and we're done.
We now have version 2 running.
We've done a nice canary rollout
with Kubernetes and Istio.
So to add this little kind
of funky advanced topic
into the mix.
Imagine we have some
really critical customers.
We're really, really concerned
that they should not have
a breaking application on them.
So we really want to make sure
that when we do a candidate
evaluation, they don't get
sent to the old version,
or the new version, rather.
So we can do content header
based rooting in this case
to do that.
I'll skip through
this a little bit.
You can define a match rule
that matches specifically
on the header.
And you can say under
these circumstances
always send to my old subset.
Oh, are we missing a slide here?
No.
Always send to my
old application.
And one thing that is
obviously worth bearing in mind
that if you have these
kind of rules, the traffic
distribution-- that's
what that little star is--
changes a little bit
because of course,
the people that match
this specific condition
are going to the old version.
And so you end up with 95-5
of the remaining traffic.
All right, quick overview
of the recommended pattern
that we talked about here.
In the steady
state, you only need
to keep the running
version of your application
using a deployment object.
When you start your rollout,
and you want to do a canary,
you create two new resources,
a candidate and a baseline.
You use the deployment
config of the existing
version for the baseline.
And you use the
deployment config
of the new version
for the candidate.
You send-- you add subsets
to your destination rule,
and appropriate
weight distribution
to your virtual service.
It's useful if you're
automating this,
if you think of the
weights as parameters
to your automation scripting
or your automation tool,
because that makes it easy to
do a multi-step canary that you
can easily go from
80-10-10 to or 90
or towards 60-20-20,
something like that.
And you should definitely use
a Horizontal Pod Autoscaler
for your baseline
and your candidate,
so that they ramp up as
the traffic comes up.
So then you wait, gather
data, and you make a decision.
If you're good to go
after the canary analysis,
you just update the deployment
that represents your running up
and get rid of the rest.
And you can remove the
subsets from the destination
rule and the weights
from the virtual service.
And of course, you can
get rid of the candidate
and the baseline workloads.
There's lots of
shortcuts possible here.
You can, for instance, keep
the candidate in the baseline
around and have them spun down.
And that means that
your yaml changes
might be a little simpler.
But this is the sort of
cleanest and nicest approach,
because in your
steady state, you only
have one running workload,
and everything else
is ephemeral during the
course of the rollout.
So, speed up a bit.
This could be an entire
talk in its own right.
One thing worth
pointing out here
is that the rollout
that we looked at
represents a sequence of
six or seven config changes.
And if you're thinking
of a get up style pattern
where you want to capture the
intended state of your runtime
in a repo, the question becomes
how do you reflect these config
changes in that repo?
Clearly, you don't want
to have your users do
cube-ctl six or
seven times as you're
doing this canary analysis.
So automation tooling really
should be updating this repo.
Another approach that we see
some of the community tooling
take is to basically hide
this kind of canary pattern
inside the CRD.
So you post something
like a canary rollout.
And it magically makes
all the resources for you
and runs however long it runs.
And that's possible, but
one of the things it does
is it means that your
repository doesn't really
reflect the actual
state of your cluster
very well, because you think
you have one deployment,
but you actually have three.
And so we think having your
automation tooling make
these updates back
into your repository
is a good mix between making
it simple for the user--
they just need to say
deploy with canary--
and between having
a representation
of your actual
cluster state so that
you can see at any given time
what was really going on.
A couple more.
Yes, so a final summary here.
Three main takeaways
from my side.
You can implement canary
roll-outs and other strategies
that go beyond the
vanilla deployment
object in Kubernetes.
And you can do that pretty
easily using vanilla Kubernetes
ID resources or, if you want
more sophistication for canary,
you can use Istio.
Add that, and it
gives you two nice--
at least two nice-- powerful
features including traffic
shaping and also
content-based routing.
And then if you want
a recommended sequence
of config changes
for your resources
as you want to do
a canary rollout,
well, we have one in
the slides over here.
You can easily automate the
set of config changes using
Spinnaker, as we'll see
right now, or indeed,
a bunch of other tools.
And now to actually see what
this looks like for real,
let's hand it over to Nora.
NORA LUTZ: Thanks
so much, Andrew.
[APPLAUSE]
Awesome.
A lot of great information.
Thanks so much.
So before we get
into our demo here,
I want to talk
just really quickly
about who Descartes Labs
is, what we're doing,
why canary roll-outs are
actually very important to us.
So at Descartes, we're
focusing on building models
of the physical world, things
like agriculture, supply
chains, transportation,
energy production.
Four years ago, the
founder spun out
Descartes Labs from the Los
Alamos National Laboratory
after incubating their
underlying machine learning
technology for many years.
So then we took that
and built a software
as a service platform
on top of GCP
that our customers can leverage
to build their own machine
learning models,
utilizing petabytes
of remote sensing
geospatial data.
So to comprise the platform,
we use about every GCP product
available, I think, except
for maybe the exception
of App Engine and Spanner.
So here's one quick example
of how we build these models.
This is a natural color imagery
of farmland in Greenfield, Iowa
taken from [INAUDIBLE] two.
And here's that same
imagery after going
through our pipeline.
So our platform has empowered
our applied scientists
to segment up that
imagery into boundaries
of towns, fields, roads.
We then took a machine
learning classification model
on just the fields to show
corn and soy field boundaries.
And then we took
that a step further,
and we were able to use the
non-human visible spectrum
of light and seeing how
travels through the plant
to see how much fruit
the plant is growing.
And then we scaled that
up using Kubernetes,
using hundreds of thousands
of cores, tens of thousands
of pods.
So we can view this growth
every single day on every field
everywhere in the United States.
So why am I up here talking
about canary releases?
Obviously Dev Ops is not
our core business model,
but we need it to always be
improving our feature velocity.
We need to move faster.
We need to add new capabilities
and continue scaling
up our platform.
But we want to do this
without introducing issues
that have cascading effects
across our complex interlocking
services.
Detecting problems
when new features
are released to production
is actually pretty hard.
But what if we could
have a way to detect them
before they went truly live?
And we wanted to
do all of this with
minimal human intervention.
Humans are good.
Humans are great.
Engineers with lots of
operational experience
are wonderful, but
they're not infallible.
To be able to sustainably
meet our goals,
we need a nuanced and
fully automated approach.
So these are some of
the circumstances that
led us to investigate
tools to help us do things
like canary analysis
and canary deployments.
What we found when we were
trying to solve this problem
can be split the
three main categories.
I'll briefly go over those.
We looked at things like
continuous delivery.
We looked at tools like GitLab,
which is a very mature delivery
system that required a lot of
buying into their ecosystem.
We also looked at
a lot of things
like jenkins
scripts, which seemed
a bit heavyweight
for our use case,
kind of like bringing a chainsaw
where we needed a scalpel,
and also, the story
to implement carries
was not as clear at the
time we looked at it.
And then finally, we
looked at Spinnaker,
which is an open source project
spun out on Netflix, for those
not familiar.
It has a feature-rich
Kubernetes v2 provider
that supports complex pipelines,
consuming and producing
Kubernetes native objects.
And hopefully, it also
supports canary analysis
through something
called Kayenta.
And then next, we're looking
to get those metrics to be
able to do our canary analysis.
We need to be able to do those
fine grain traffic splits.
So, lucky for us, we're already
using Istio in production.
So we didn't have to
look very far there.
And then finally, when we
looked how to actually implement
this in practice, how to
do these canary analyses,
we actually, at the time
we looked last year,
didn't find a very consistent
pattern or best practices
guidelines as reported
by the community.
In fact, what we did
find at that time
was a lot of
conflicting approaches.
And so of course,
here today I'm going
to introduce one more approach
for you all to consider.
So here's what we
use at Descartes
to power continuous deployment
pipelines with canaries.
My hope is that you're
going to take away
some ideas and
concepts on how this
can work at your organizations.
So we have Spinnaker with
Kayenta of a canary analysis.
We have Kubernetes.
Our Kubernetes all run on GKE.
And then finally, we have Istio.
So before I hop into
the demo, I want
to show you where we're
starting from, like,
what is the current
state of affairs?
We have our service here tiles.
This is a real
service that we use
to scale up analysis over
large geographic areas
by splitting them into a
grid of smaller sized tiles.
We have our deployment
object, our service object.
And then we have our Istio
virtual service tiles release,
which routes all of
our production traffic
to our Kubernetes service.
And then finally, we
have our ingress gateway,
which is receiving and
routing all of our traffic
coming into our service mesh.
So what we're going
to try and do today
is update live to production
a version two of this app
right here on stage.
So let's go ahead
and head to the demo.
All right, perfect.
So here we have
our Spinnaker UI.
Now don't worry if you
haven't seen this before.
It's a lot going on.
And come talk to me after
if you want to talk more
about the details of this.
And we're going to
spend a lot of time
talking about the
intricacies of configuring
canaries for analysis.
So I'm not going to spend a lot
of time on Spinnaker concept
as much as how you fine
tune your canary analysis.
Because it's not just magic.
When I pull back the curtain,
it's actually pretty nuanced.
So anyway, let's move on.
In our case, we're
using the version
two provider, which allows us
to manage many of our Kubernetes
kinds, deployments being one
of those, and also Istio kinds.
Most relevantly
to our discussion
here is going to be
our virtual service.
We have our application
canary, which isn't actually
a one to one mapping
with tiles, but it
does contain our
pipeline that we're
concerned about here, which is
our next demo canary pipeline.
So if we click through, we can
see that our pipeline contains
artifacts, parameters, and
stages, stages consumed
as artifacts and parameters.
Some of them are
canary analysis stages.
And in our case--
let's go here--
the artifacts we're
concerned with for the
tile service itself.
So we have our deployment
manifest captured in GitHub.
We have our virtual service.
And then finally, we have our
tiles image, which is in GCR.
So let's finally
just jump into it.
Let's kick off the pipeline.
I'm going to start a
manual execution here.
And I'm going to supply
an image tag, which
of course, is now not copied,
because my computer turned off.
Thank you, demagods.
So we supplied this
as a parameter to bind
to our correct image in GCR
in our deployment manifest.
Normally, this pipeline will
be triggered by a Pub/Sub.
So when a new tag
is made available,
the tag would then
be sent to Spinnaker
as part of the payload.
So let's talk a little
bit about these stages
as they start to run through.
We have our get image from
production stage, which
produces an artifact, namely
our tiles image that's currently
running in our tiles released
deployment version one.
So this is what
Andrew talked about.
You need to get
the images running
in production to be able to
feed that to your baseline.
So that's a pretty
critical moment.
This is going to be
consumed on the next stage.
So now we have our canaries and
our baseline being deployed.
Canary is going to be deployed
with the candidate release
image tag, baseline
with the image tag
that we obtain from
our previous stage.
Something to note here,
baselines and canaries
are using identical Horizontal
Pod Autoscalers, deployments,
and service objects.
So this helps us eliminate
variations that could affect
adversely analysis results.
So, once those finish
deploying, our virtual service
is going to be updated
for the first time.
To shift a percentage
of production traffic
away from the production release
and towards the canary baseline
pair--
So we're going to start
by shifting 10% of traffic
to each the canary
and baseline services,
and keep 80% running
to our release.
We have several
stages in our pipeline
that manipulate the virtual
service for tiles release.
So we increase the weighting as
we go so more and more traffic
heads to canary and baseline.
Something I think it's
worth pointing out here
is that instead of maintaining
versioning of virtual service
manifest for each and every
of these combinations,
we're parameterizing this
using something called
Spinnaker Expressions.
And these are going to be
evaluated during each stage.
So let's go back here and--
all right.
So at this point our virtual
service is then [INAUDIBLE] out
and deployed.
And we're going to move on
to our first canary analysis
stage.
So this stage is
powered by Kayenta.
This is a canary analysis
service released jointly
by Google and Netflix that
aggregates and compares
metrics for judgment whether
a canary is healthy relative
to a baseline.
As I mentioned, this is now
integrated into Spinnaker,
and can be enabled.
I'm not going to
go into that here.
But it's fully documented.
And we're happy to
talk about that later.
So there's two main
areas of configuration
when it comes to
canary analysis.
And the first is
our canary config.
So in our canary config,
we're to specify metrics
that we want to compare between
a baseline and a canary.
Not shown here, but actually
very relevant to this,
is our telemetry provider.
We can't compare anything if we
don't have metric information.
In this case, our
Istio metrics are
being exported to Stackdriver.
So we're going to use
Stackdriver for our use case,
but you can also use things
like Prometheus, Datadog,
and others.
So what key metric do we
actually care about for tiles?
What do we want to
analyze when we're trying
to add a new candidate release?
Response latency
to client requests
is one metric that's
pretty important.
We want retrieval of
tiles of rasterized data
to be quick, so as not to
impede higher level analysis.
So let's go ahead and
click into that metric.
We should think of these
metrics as a set of templates
that for queries, they're
going to execute it
against your telemetry
store for both
your baseline and your canary.
We're going to define
failure depending
on whether the canary metric is
seen to increase statistically
relative to our baseline.
In this case, we want to fail
their response latency is
higher coming from the canary.
We chose a resource type that
represents a set of time series
data that we want to measure,
in this case Kubernetes pod.
We're going to need to
choose a metric type that has
data specific to this resource.
So Istio exposes all sorts
of great metrics right out
of the box that you can use.
In our case, we're measuring
client round latencies.
And so this is a distribution
of latency values.
We then want to use things
like grouping and filtering
to further refine
date these data points
that you want to compare.
Being able to get that
exactly the right data
that you want to compare is
the biggest part of the nuance
here.
So we're going to filter
out unhealthy responses--
anything not a 200
series response.
In other metrics you may care
very well very much about
whether or not it's
healthier or unhealthy.
But in this case, we want to
consider healthy responses.
We want to filter on
the destination workload
name, which is going to resolve
to either tiles base line
or tiles canary.
Remember, these are templates.
Where our namespace is
tiles, and request is a post.
Because in this
particular execution path
that we're testing,
receives post requests.
And then we're going to
take that and actually
clean that up and aggregate
that a little further.
We're going to help smooth out
this distribution for a better
comparison using aggregators,
aligners, and reducers.
So we want to choose
the 50th percentile
value of each
latency distribution
as a single data point for the
whole period of one minute.
And why do we do this?
One of the reasons
we do this is we
want to safeguard in our
analysis against things
like a random expensive request
or a series of those, network
failures, things like that.
They don't creep in
and accidentally cause
false negatives and positives.
So by aggregating
this data, you're
going to be able to have a more
apples to apples comparison.
So let's go back here.
If you do choose to analyze
more than one metric, which
is probably recommended,
these can be grouped.
And those groups can be
weighted in importance.
One example of why you
might want to do this--
in our case, we chose
latency, but if we also
had error rate as one of our
metrics, in this scenario,
latency metric analysis
shows that it's
near identical performance
between canary and baseline.
And so the analysis
is successful,
but error rate is significantly
higher in the canary.
So they should
probably be weighted
higher as it has much
more severe implications
for your service health and
for your customer experience.
And then finally, I'll briefly
touch on scoring thresholds.
So our marginal score
is the moon value
that a canary analysis can
have and still proceed on
to further analyses.
And our path score is
the minimum score value
that the final analysis
should have in order
to pass for the entire stage.
In our case, we're only
measuring one metric.
So it's kind of a
binary operation.
Either you failed,
0, or passed, 100.
So we set our metric, our scores
to 99 and 100 respectively.
So the second piece
of this puzzle
is the analysis stage itself.
In the stage config
we want to specify
how Kayenta is going to operate
for this particular analysis
stage.
We're going to set our
analysis to real time
to measure our deployments
that are running right now.
But you could also set
this to retrospective.
So if you have a
canary and baseline
pair that have been running
in the past days, past weeks,
past months even, you could have
this do the exact same analysis
over that period of time.
But for this demo,
we set real time.
We set our config name.
But I think the most
important value to set here,
the most important
thing to think
about is the lifetime value.
Currently, we have it
set to three minutes.
Not very long time.
That's what this demo.
And I'll go into why
this is so important.
In order for your comparison
to be accurate and not
reflect more potential false
negatives or positives,
you want to set a
long enough lifetime
to gather enough data points
to ensure that anomalies
don't skew your analysis.
So you want to set a long
time to gather this data.
We also set our base line
and a canary namespace
and deployments here.
So after our analysis
run is complete,
we can view our analysis
report once Spinnaker loads.
So in this amplitude
versus time chart--
let me zoom out a little bit, so
you can see all of this at once
hopefully.
In this amplitude
versus time chart,
you can that the
comparison of time series
data we filtered out from
our Istio client round trip
latency as metric.
So it looks like
our canary is not
introducing statistically
significant higher
latency than the baseline.
And so our analysis is
successful, which is great.
You can also view things
like the maximum minimum,
and average latency
data points gleaned
from our 50th
percentile time series.
And if you actually click
through here to your metrics,
you can see all of
your data points
that were gathered
throughout the lifetime.
But you're probably
thinking, well Nora,
this doesn't look
very impressive.
It's three data points.
And this actually
highlights one of the issues
with such a short lifetime.
With a period of one minute and
an analysis lifetime of three,
that only allows for three
data points to be aggregated.
With such a small
sample size, analysis
results maybe less
than representative.
So it's very key that you
spend enough time gathering
this data, on the order of hours
and days, not just minutes.
So, now that our
analysis is successful,
we're going to move on.
The pipeline is going to move
on and increase the weights
to our canary baseline pair.
Let's go ahead and head back
to the slides real fast.
So, at this point, we're
starting to adjust our weights.
We're updating that
virtual service
to set our traffic
to 20, 20, and 60.
And as this occurs,
our traffic and thus,
the CPU across each deployment
is going to increase.
And so our horizontal
[INAUDIBLE]
scale is going to begin to scale
our baseline and tiles release
as a function of the load.
One of the ways to visualize
this is with Stackdriver.
Here's a chart I created
to view the current numbers
of tiles pods as reflected
by their CPU request counts.
You can see our release
deployment scaling up and down
as a function of traffic, while
our canary and baseline are
also scaling up to meet the
demand as virtual service
weights are increased.
So, eventually our
virtual service
will have weighted
the canary in baseline
to receive 80% of traffic.
So we're pretty
confident at this point
we've got a healthy release.
And then we're going to perform
the final analysis currently
using our same config and
stage parameters as before.
The reason you might
do multiple analyses
is because behavior is going
to change as your candidate
scales up.
As you scale, it's going to
introduce potential issues,
things like memory
leaks or a slow burning
bug, that sort of thing.
So having multiple
periods as you scale
is going to give you more
confidence that your candidate
is actually healthy.
So if that's successful,
our release deployment
is updated to use our new
tiles image tag, version 2.
And then we're going to begin
reversing this weighting
process, letting our
tiles release deployment
scale back up gradually
as it receives more
and more of the traffic again.
This is so we don't shock
the system so to speak.
As our release has scaled
down, if we reintroduced
100% of traffic, that could
have a spike from latencies,
failures,
unpredictable behavior.
So we want to start scaling
down our baseline first,
because this is at the oldest
deployment at this point,
and scaling up our
production release.
Then we scale down
the canary until we
have our successful release.
It's important to note
that regardless of success
or failure, the canary and
baseline deployments are
deleted, and tiles released
is reset to receive
100% of traffic via
our virtual service.
This is implemented
by another pipeline
that's triggered after
the previous is completed
or failed.
So to wrap up, here
are some pro tips
I can give you guys
when you're looking
to implement this yourself.
Choose metrics that reflect
key service health indicators.
So if your candidate release
was to go into production,
choose what you would
care to measure.
If you already have things
like service level indicators,
have those established.
It's a great starting place.
Accruing a large
enough sample size
and aligning the data for
apples to apples comparisons
is critical to avoid false
negatives and false positives.
Having identical
baselines carries
and releases, except
for image tag,
helps ensure that you're
examining the right difference
between your service instances.
Change one variable
for your analysis.
And I didn't go
over it very much,
but every deployment Horizontal
Pod Autoscaler, service
and virtual service
was fully parameterized
with Spinnaker expressions.
This meant I can
avoid having diversion
of potentially hundreds
or thousands of manifests,
and dynamically
populate them at runtime
with Spinnaker parameters.
This is a really powerful
feature of Spinnaker,
and should absolutely
be taking advantage of.
And then finally,
the way Kayenta
interprets these metrics
labels some Stackdriver is
a little bit opaque.
So since we're
using Stackdriver,
I personally found
that using the metrics
explorer very, very helpful
in teasing out those mappings.
So taking advantage of the
tools that your metrics store
provides to help
you get this right.
So canary analysis
and CD for Kubernetes
is an ever-moving target.
We want to work with you
guys, the community, to help
shape these patterns and tools.
I'd recommend checking out
the Spinnaker Kubernetes
special interest group and
the hashtag Kubernetes channel
on Spinnaker Slack to join in.
And then finally, a little plug.
Come check us out at
DescartesLabs.com.
If you're interested in
using our platform to power
your geospatial machine
learning models,
or just curious about
what we have to offer,
check out our API's at
docs.DescartesLabs.com.
And if you also have a
love for geospatial data,
modeling the earth, want
to solve tough engineering
challenges, check our Jobs
page or just shoot us an email
at hello@DescartesLabs.com.
All right.
ANDREW PHILIPS: Thank you, Nora.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]